all right 5 16 on your Friday morning
what's cool it's cool how about
congratulations to the Clark County
School District's 2023 Junior Reserve
officer training Corps ROTC drill team
champions from Bonanza High School
continuing a winning tradition that
started four years ago bonanza's Army
Junior ROTC team won this year's CCSD
Championship last Saturday at Sunrise
Mountain High School from Individual
skills to color guard the young men and
women underwent numerous inspections
they were inside they were outside and
when all the scores were tallied Bonanza
first sergeant Greg Sanders tell us 8
news now the Bengals coached by sergeant
major David oberg won their fourth
consecutive drill team championship
making not only the students proud but
also their parents some sporting
t-shirts saying loud and proud ROTC mom
and I have no life my kids on the drill
team
I love that shirt all right now Sergeant
Sanders says the uh Bonanza army JROTC
team is heading to the national
competition next month in Florida
congratulations you know we always want
to know what's cool it's cool you got
something let us know cool it's cool
under the Community tab of our website
or you can just email cool at school at
8newsnow.com and Heather you're
absolutely right the Precision that
these young men and women have they're
also throwing those rifles around at
each other and catching them it's
amazing to me to watch it I can't do
anything in unison with anyone so
whenever I see them like in parades and
they're doing their drills I would
always feel like I'd be the one as they
are going left I'm going to go right